good morning
Millennials welcome back to the toast
and
happy Friday Friday gotta get down on
Friday everybody's looking forward to
the weekend weekend Friday Friday
getting down a
Friday fun fun fun fun looking forward
to the
weekend you know she was really on to
something when she said fun fun fun fun
four times the fun and that's exactly
what I'm looking forward to this weekend
hey turo how you ding I'm ding well you
look gorgeous do I finally wearing the
birthday gift that I got you years and
years ago perhaps the most money I've
ever spent on a birthday gift and one
that she wears the least less a yearo
it's a shirt from The Gap you got it for
me for my last birthday so it's been
less than a year
I love this necklace and I always like
think to wear it I always like try to
wear it but I don't know something
always comes up the last time I wore it
on the show was like one day my video
was out of focus and like no one could
it's kind of cursed so hopefully
everything goes well today what did you
say about a shirt from The Gap that's
what you're getting next year Oh I
thought you were like saying something
about my shirt today no you look so
gorgeous your hair is up it's a Friday
and jackon cler are back together I mean
what's better than that especially
coming out of like a sickening week for
the toast in my opinion sickening week
for the toast all of our favorite things
one short week two Cody rby three PBO
four Jack's twice original recipe on the
show what could be better no literally
nothing I have glowing reviews tens tens
tens across the board for everyone who
showed up this week Cody rsby was a
dream like I was obsessed with him like
actually like like a friend crush I like
at the end I was like let me know if you
ever want to get drinks he was like yeah
like sure I've met you once sure um and
then Paige I feel like I called you
yesterday just raving about Paige and
this is what I've learned through just
the maternity leave process and just
having guest co-hosts is like I'm really
hesitant now moving forward to have
someone on who's not a podcaster because
you know people are going to say this is
like a crazy thing to say podcasting is
a skill it is a talent and it needs to
be honed and Paige is the perfect
example of that I feel that way about
Hannah too she just the perfect
podcaster she's so good at talking and
listening and creating new conversations
going on tangents making good points
like it's a skill and I stand by that
and I not a slide at anyone who's ever
come on the toast who doesn't have a
podcast but I feel like it's a
guaranteed good episode when I'm
podcasting with a podcaster yeah and
also there is a very big difference
between like being a co-host filling in
for me and being a guest on the show
like when you are a co-host you're here
to work kind of it's not just like all
about about you and you're answering and
you don't have to like give yeah but I
do feel like the line is blurred when
it's someone who is would be a guest a
great guest but they're also coming to
do the Fast Five yeah no and what I've
learned and and maybe gotten a little
comfortable with is like the idea of
have because I'm going to LA in a few
weeks when when you're still on
maternity leave and I I I want to get
some people on who are obviously like
guest co-hosts but I also am comfortable
with the idea of like maybe if I get
someone who's not like a podcaster but
who's like promoting something and is
like a a celebrity maybe not making them
do the Fast Five with me but just doing
like what everyone else does like a
podcast interview yeah kind of how I did
with like Jay shett and Taylor lner last
time I was in
LA yeah you know yeah it depends on the
person I understand that so I'm excited
to be here back with you after such a
great week I was kind of like out on a
school night last night I got dressed in
state alert and even though you did not
find what you were looking for yeah I
really thought I was gonna see Taylor
Swift out and about last night I just I
feel like she's in New York the city has
like this energy to it where you could
tell she's landed and I went to you know
a local hot spot of hers she was not
there but it didn't diminish from the
amazing time I had finally meeting I I
can't believe I never met we talk about
R parcel literally all the time on this
podcast I just feel like and we talk all
the time like we DM and we text I just
didn't like I didn't think I put
together that I've never actually met
her and her sisters until I was on my
way to dinner I'm like oh my God this is
so crazy with had the best
time I'm so jealous I know I'm sorry
it's okay I'm glad you had a great time
and you recapped me of all the fun that
was I called Jackie from the cab home it
was me Margo Emily ra and Amy Amy um and
it was just fabulous and it's so funny
because I feel like I sat down and I had
like so many questions for them about
just like Mormon culture living in Utah
and they also came with a thousand
questions about like Jewish culture
living in New York they're like you grew
up here like so many different questions
and it was really honestly an exchange
of information which is my favorite type
of conversation yep it's an exchange of
information nothing nothing more than a
farious than that is Bruno barking is
someone breaking into your home no I
think I heard the doorbell but you'll
hear The Barking but I don't think the
podcast the listeners will hear it
that's because I use a sure microphone
that is sure to only pick up what I'm
saying hopefully hopefully sometimes it
picks up the trucks so I was just and
Bruno has a Bruno has a bark that's
unlike he's not like other dogss no
Bruno has a bark that's like four times
his size yeah it's it'll go to the
center of your brain but that's mommy's
Angel stri
Sands oh well sometimes he gets into
like his cute baby bark where he's like
I'm so small tiny and scared yeah he's
kind of looking for attention and then
sometimes he's like he's like don't you
come knocking down my door he's a giving
guard dog he's giving guard dog he has
like so many many loved ones that he
needs to protect that I understand
mhm so it was just amazing getting to me
you know they say never meet your Heroes
but I did and I survived and it was
amazing yeah some a lot I get to meet a
lot of Heroes through this line of work
yeah and most of the time it's
great yeah I agree so I wonder why they
say that I wonder who their Heroes were
obviously not the sisters parcel no like
who were they talking to obviously not
K obviously not Frank actually thank you
for reminding me Frank was in my dream
what was he up to I think there okay do
you remember guys remember that episode
My Big Fat Gypsy
Wedding the episode on TLC no no do you
remember that TV Show on TLC My Big Fat
Gypsy Wedding basically it was about
Gypsy culture which I was unfamiliar
with and how their weddings are like
these crazy spectacles they wear like
400 PB dresses and their hair like
Teresa's at her wedding but times five
but almost without fail every single
episode an enormous brawl breaks out on
the street about with like a cousin and
an in-law and it ends up into like a
Beatdown that's how it ends up and there
was a Beatdown on the side of the street
with like the cast of real housewi of
New Jersey and Frank and I were there
just kind of like breaking it up that's
so you guys I feel like that could
happen yeah was it a gypsy wedding or
you're just like making that comparison
no it wasn't a gypsy wedding but
visually it was very similar to the art
of a brawl at a gypsy wedding got it
okay cool I'm actually been very
interested in Gypsy culture because
really yes cuz I was watching um Fury
family I forget what their Show's called
at home with the furies and they're
Gypsies and he calls himself the Gypsy
King it's like his whole
thing oh my God so the like Tommy's
family is Gypsy Tommy's family is Gypsy
and his older brother who's the big
wrestler Tyson Fury he's the Gypsy King
and not wrestling Jackie that's really
offensive it's like boxing oh sorry
that's really offensive sorry I'm still
learning a lot about the sport obviously
and I'm and I'm open to listening and
learning and doing better doing better
yeah I really am so he's the big boxer
and him and his wife our gypsies they
have like a big uh Gypsy family his dad
and you learn a lot about their culture
from the show so that's very interesting
I should watch My Big Fat Gypsy Wedding
you 100% should there was a time in my
life where that was my favorite show
it's so crazy and it's so good and so
interesting I did not know they were
gypsies yeah I didn't know either and so
Tommy is Gypsy and so him and Molly like
were talking about some of the Gypsy
things that they will incorporate into
their life some of the things that they
won't and you know what's even more
interesting H the band The Gypsy
Kings I don't think they're
Gypsy and does Tyson Fury have an beef
or you know a warm spot in his heart or
do they have like trademark issues and
Gypsy is one of those words that like
when you say too many times garage it
starts to sound weird
yeah
Mako bu if we Gypsy toasters comment
below LMK let us know about your culture
let us know about Gypsy representation
in popular media what do you think about
Tyson what do you think about the Gypsy
Kings I'm sure they like Tyson and I'm
sure they don't like My Big Fat Gypsy
Wedding I'm sure that's what also we
were talking about at um dinner last
night there like really are so many
similarities in just like Mormon culture
and Jewish culture like family they were
like what do you do at Temple I'm like
it's exactly what you do at CH I mean at
church um and re was like I know so much
about Judaism from the toast because I
listen every day I'm like I know so much
about Mormonism because I'm a Stan yeah
and and you guys also have like things
in the culture that like you frown upon
and you think like reflects your
religion
poorly yes yes oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah things that's we were talking about
like things in media like I think shows
on Netflix like unorthodox and my
unorthodox life are like so damaging and
like a really poor representation of my
culture and I don't I don't um claim
those shows like I think they're full of
lies and I'm sure you know like they
have the things of their own like that
too yeah did they mention anything about
Real Housewives of Salt Lake City um
they did they were like it's good they
they love Bravo so like they enjoyed the
show I don't think they would ever be on
it and I think like their take was that
when the show came out like those
weren't like it's it's really good and
all those women are really interesting
but those weren't like the obvious
choices for people being selected like
in the in the landscape of socialites in
Utah they were like surprised they had
never heard of most of the women
understood yeah cool well what a fun
night out in the city it really was we
missed you dearly I miss you guys but
I'll be seeing you soon you guys next
week the week after next I'm coming to
New York camper counselor is is coming
out on Tuesday October 10th hey Jack
sorry what's camper and counselor camper
and C the camper and the counselor is a
children's book that I have written it's
my first stab in the literary world and
I think it's a really really good one no
and like you're making waves in the
literary World Making Waves in the
literary World Making Waves amongst the
children you can pre-order the book now
it comes out October 10th and it is so
good I was reading it last night to
Harry and I was just kept getting more
more that's like more that's my
equivalent of a standing ovation more
more more I was like really me no I'm
shy I all I have to do is close my eyes
and I can read the whole book you know
yeah and it's really a visual experience
it is a visual experience the
illustrations are so beautiful colorful
they're really A Feast for the child's
eyes and the caretaker reading the book
The rhyming is on point there's no
Rhymes that was something when I was
writing the book like the first draft
had a lot of almost Rhymes where it was
like um words that sound really similar
but they're not like 100% Rhymes or even
like friends rhyming with end no it's
got to be friend and end I agree and
there are no almost Rhymes every rhyme
is a 100% fit the I Amic
pamer not a beat is Mist no if you have
like a little bit of OCD some children's
books can be [__] infuriating like
just rhyme [__] and your book scratches
the itch perfectly thank you there are
some children's books where there's
always like there's one sentence that I
always kind of like edit can't either
edit or I like can't figure out the beat
yeah no the beat in a children's book is
such an important factor that I don't
think enough authors not to like come
for other children's authors but I don't
think they take it seriously enough and
you did yeah because we're so musically
inclined the beat is so important to us
no and music and I'm I'm being like
actually serious now like music and
Rhythm and beats are so like such a huge
part of like kid culture like there
every toy has a song every show has a
song like music and kids is like really
a an important friendship and I think
the literary world has forgotten that
music and children go together like
Jackson Claude like peanut butter and
jelly that's so us I I would literally
love a peanut butter and jelly sandwich
right now that's like one thing I'll
never stop eating I've been eating it
since I was a kid and I'll be eating it
till the day I die yeah I go through
phases with formula it is like I go
through phases with food you know
there's a lot of [__] I ate as a kid I
would never eat now but like peanut
butter stands the test of time peanut
butter and jelly and like I could see
myself in the nursing home like kicking
it with a PB&J
yeah okay I'll make sure to bring you
one so you won't be in a nursing home
with me where the hell will you
be I don't know we got like plans big
plans if I go down you're going down too
honestly I feel like nursing homes are
like frowned upon it's like kind of like
the last resort for a lot of people no
not me if my sisters are coming with me
like we're lightting the place up [__]
it has to be a nice one not one where
like you know the nurses like are elder
abuse elder abuse is so real and I get
that's why like my nursing homes have a
bad rap but like a nice facility perhaps
in like a a warm you know Florida suburb
like put sign me up [__] like we could
do pickle ball like our days are so our
days are our own yeah well I think that
you're describing sounds like a senior
living yeah more more like a retirement
community you're right cuz a nursing
home I guess is more like bed pan more
like bed pan you know yeah yeah no okay
a retirement facility I would love only
if all you guys came with me yeah I'm
down we could still podcast from the
retirement community and we will even if
it's just for the community and you know
like I feel like the Crush of a
retirement facility is like they plan a
million activities a day it's like
there's Bingo there's tennis there's
singles night like I love activities
it's kind of like Camp it is it is Camp
I wonder if they have bonfires I wonder
if they have the camer and the counselor
they should for the grandkids who come
to visit the
grandkids so if you have grandkids and
you're listening you got to get camper
and counselor pre-order it today Amazon
Talk Shop live Barnes & Noble books a
million in debound truly wherever you
pre-order your books it's going to be
amazing I'm so excited for people to
read it like that's what I'm so excited
for is like the way I felt when I like
read it for the first time when it was
like complete I'm so excited for people
to have that feeling and to like get
that feedback I I seriously can't wait
yeah when you were done with it you uh
facetimed me and like not me literally
getting teary eyed on FaceTime over a
children's book I was like this is It's
Magic in a book yeah and now that I've
read it probably 3,000 times I like
forget that initial feeling you know
yeah it's worn off a little bit but then
every few days if I like come back to it
I'm like oh my God this is so precious
and not to make everything about um me
MH but I really obviously I want this
book to be successful because I want you
to have success I love you but mostly
because it creates an opportunity for
you to write a second one that's not
inspired by snitch but inspired by me
yeah and so if you guys love Claudia and
you want to see her get everything She
Wants in this world please pre-order my
book because the chances of then me
writing a sequel about tur's Great
Adventures like if the book flops you're
not going to do it
again yeah I I guess that's how that
works yeah so we need it not to flop so
I can get what I want yeah and so would
you want like a total new world like
tury Adventures or do you want to join
the bunk no [__] I want my own and I
want it to do better than counselors
like if it comes to the point where you
do write a second book and it isn't
inspired by me and like the character's
name is like Trudy or tury like we'll
figure we'll figure out semantic it
can't be tury I know unless it's a book
about potty training even still like I
don't I think that's a bit of a stretch
even choosing to keep her name counselor
snitch was a choice yeah okay maybe
Trudy L I want that thankfully we have
that voicemail and now you're Trudy L
yes so I want trudo's Adventures to be
like its own thing and it has to outsell
the camper and the counselor even though
like a second book never Sala first I
don't know they've never seen Trudy Lou
they haven't by the way I wanted to ask
you are there any stories that I spoke
about with Cody or page that you want to
give your take on such a great question
I was actually looking at all the
stories that you guys discussed I have
an actually right here are you going to
visit the Airbnb of Shrek swamp I would
love to where is it located
Scotland in the Rolling Hills of
Scotland that sounds beautiful magical I
saw such a funny tweet being
like I really don't appreciate them
glamorizing his swamp when he was led to
live in a swamp because of being a
tree like it's it's not cool it's
actually a fire Point yeah but it's also
giving you live there by choice it's
giving Bloom where you're
planted that's exactly what Shrek did
that's exactly what Shrek did he made
the most like he was driven out he was
forced to live in a swamp now we're
glamorizing it but let's not forget like
what a swamp truly is and he made the
most and he bloomed where he was planted
and it became like the hottest spot in
town yeah it's beautiful we could all
learn a little something from Shrek
there's so many lessons that's just one
of them yeah uh so that is really
exciting I don't have the bandwidth to
go to Scotland but if I did I would go
that would be your first stop and oh
what's the Courtney's baby name that
they're saying is the name they're
saying it's going to like they they
think that they accidentally slipped it
on social media and that the baby's name
is Rocky so cute I hope it is so cute I
kind of like it too Rocky Barker by the
way do we have any Kardashian stories
today we do not okay did you watch the
first episode no did you I did I'm
desperate to watch it but I am plowing
through the new redheads book we're
reading the fourth wing and I just want
to say quick redheads plug this is the B
buzziest book of the year the fourth
Wing I'm sure you've heard of it Rebecca
yaros it's like fantasy snitch chose it
and we were so curious to be like what
is this book that's capturing the nation
especially it's about like Dungeons and
Dragons you know right so good and it's
smut I haven't gotten to the smut yet
but apparently the smut is smutting I
feel like I'm about to hit smut cuz like
I got a kiss you know yeah yeah yeah um
but I did watch Kardashians and there
while there was a lot to talk about it
was truly so boring like I was in shock
they how could those two things be true
because it all happened in the beginning
Maybe like the first 10 minutes well
that's better than all at the end Jackie
the rest of the episode like they spent
maybe 20 minutes having a guacamole
making competition Kendall and Kylie
versus Kim and
Courtney that's unfortunate then they
did like another 10 minutes CU they go
to Mexico and it's like whale season so
they're whale watching from the house
like they're looking at the ocean from
inside of the house Chloe screaming
she's petrified of whales goes is on
this whole thing like Jackie it was it
was really bad wow do you think that
they felt like they could put all that
crap in cuz they gave you 10 juicy
minutes like maybe and those 10 juicy
minutes like were worth it I had seen it
already on Tik Tok because I wanted to
be prepared for the toast yesterday but
then I'm like oh well if that happened
at the beginning like let's see what
else the episode was about Ben was
watching with me he was like I cannot
believe this like it was so bad like for
real and honestly like reading a bunch
of stories about the episode to prepare
for the toast and then like seeing Clips
on Tik Tok it was enough like I didn't
like moving forward if something chicy
happens like I think that's enough for
me
um but I ended up on this uh side of Tik
Tok everyone was like debunking it I had
like I watched this video of like a
therapist breaking down the whole
conversation she's like a family
therapist and she made a bunch of good
points for the most part like everyone's
on team Courtney um which is so crazy
because I feel like that's never the
case but they're now just all everyone's
so interested in how did we get here
with with Kim and Courtney like what's
really going on and I had heard a lot of
people like rumors they thought like at
one point Travis and Kim had hooked up
and I'm like they definitely didn't but
I I had known that there was stuff in
his Memoir about
Kim and I watched I I watched this video
where she broke down like everything he
wrote about Kim and like honestly it's
weird that's weird he he says like he
was in love with her and he was dating
Paris Hilton and they took a trip
together to Amsterdam and Paris broim
who was like her friend at the time and
he was immediately just taking taken by
Kim he went out of his way to see her
would follow her around and he was like
you know I thought and her sex tape had
just come out and he wrote In the book
he's like I mean I thought because of
her tape like maybe we would whatever
but it was so different I I controlled
myself I was such a gentleman I saw
something in her like it was it wasn't
just a mention it was like a whole thing
and he really wanted to date her but he
ended up trying um One Last Time with
Shan and mler to like get back together
for their family and how it just like
wasn't meant to be with him and Kim but
like he was fully in love with
her and they hung out Bunch like when
they got back from Amsterdam they spent
Fourth of July together they like did a
million things together it was it's
weird that's weird and it's like if they
hung out a bunch like that then they've
at least smooched and Jackie he wrote
that book so he wrote exactly what I
just regurgitated 10 years maybe eight
years after that trip to Amsterdam so
it's like something he still was holding
on to in 2015 okay and the book came out
in 2015 that was my next question
because now it's like then he got
together with Courtney five years after
that it's a it's enough time yeah and I
do think like people change and I don't
think that he like still holds a candle
for Kim but that is weird I'm holding a
lot of tension in my jaw I just wanted
to know if anybody saw like what I just
did on camera they're going to be like
oh my God clut is on Aderall like I'm
not my jaw is [__] killing me I think
it's the weather weather like affects my
tension why so tense I don't know I'm
feeling good it's a Jackson cler episode
we're about to rock this [__] we're
about to rock the stage at Arrowhead so
I don't know
and it's Friday I know H what do you got
going on this weekend oh you're going to
the Jets game I'm going to the Jets game
and given the weather I don't know if
anybody knows it's like crazy weather in
New York I almost didn't even come in
today like flash flood warning they
closed all the trains into the city like
the streets are flooded um so I'm
wearing my moon boots and I'm running
home after this I I don't plan on like
leaving the house or doing anything
until Sunday and hopefully the weather
clears up by Sunday oh yeah what if the
field is like Shrek swamp because I got
to see Travis Rock the stage at metti
you actually do you know what it sounds
like a chili a chili I'm so mad at
myself I made a chili on Saturday with
Ben we ate it it was made it together no
I sat in bed and he did the whole thing
Saturday we ate it Sunday I had
leftovers again and then Monday was Yom
Kor and then like Tuesday what like the
rest of the week I was just kind of
bouncing back from yum kipur and eating
everything I could like to acknowledge
my free will and I have this huge tub of
chili that I didn't freeze and I'm going
to have to throw it out it's so wasteful
I'm so annoyed it was like an amazing
chili that's upsetting I think I might
try for a chili this weekend too Chili's
a great thing with you know cuz I can't
really like dedicate that I'm going to
have how much time to cook but it's like
I could chop and then an hour later I
could come back and see her and then
kind your own yeah it's it's you can do
it on your own timeline chil's very
understanding and very forgiving
understanding and forgiving and cuz a
chili like you just throw everything in
and if it's not good just add more cumin
like you're fine yeah and how bad could
it be it really can't be bad unless like
your meat is spoiled or something you
know what I mean like yeah those flavors
together they're Harmony it'll take you
to flavor Town it will so that's my goal
for the weekend make a chili take a trip
to flavor toown
USA I I um should we dive in girly I
think that we should dive in to I agree
the fast five stories that you need to
know and the fast five stories that need
to know are brought to you by cavey the
number one dermatologist recommended
acne brand they have a line of products
developed specifically for acne prone
skin to promote a clear complexion all
formulated with three essential
ceramides so you can disrupt the acne
cycle without disrupting the Skin
Barrier feel like now that we're all
like going to be inside for the next few
months and it's cold out like our skin
is it's not glowy anymore like it's dry
it's crusty if we're prone to acne like
this is the time of year and they have a
fabulous acne line with cavey it's
salicylic acid and it works to exfoliate
and unclog your pores removing dirt and
acne caused by debris their acne control
cleanser contains 2% salicylic acid to
reduce blackheads and prevent new
breakouts it improves the appearance of
pores and contains oil absorbing
technology making it a great option for
maintaining a clear complexion and
preventing new breakouts the cavey acne
foaming cleanser cream cleanser excuse
me is a 4% benzo peroxide treatment to
clear acne pimples help prevent new
breakouts and allow skin to heal the
formula contains hyaluronic acid
niacinamide and three essential vitamins
uh ceramides to leave your skin feeling
comfortable Cy also just launched a new
10% maximum strength benzo peroxide wash
their acne foaming cream wash which is
the highest concentration without a
prescription available it clears face
and body acne so really use it in the
shower and it does so without disrupting
the Skin Barrier their am facial
moisturizing lotion and PM facial
moisturizing lotion are recommended by
dermatologists they contain three
essential ceramides to help restore
Skin's natural barrier the entire line
is great C is just such a trustworthy
brand they use simple ingredients it's
dermatologist recommended and you can be
uh purchasing them in store and online
at CVS so visit CBS in store online at
cbs.com to receive buy 1 get one 40% off
the entire cavey acne line the promotion
runs uh during specific time so make
sure you're visiting in store online at
cvs.com today's episode is also brought
to you by betterhelp thank you
betterhelp for sponsoring today's
episode do you ever find that you're
just just as you're trying to fall
asleep your brain suddenly won't stop
talking do your thoughts ever start
racing right before bed or at other
really inopportune moments well it turns
out one great way to make those racing
thoughts go away is just to talk them
through what a better place to do that
than therapy therapy gives you a place
to do that so you can get out of your
negative thought cycles and find some
mental and emotional peace finding peace
is kind of the
ultimate goal of the human experience
and therapy is kind of a great highway
to take you there not good to keep
things battled up and it can feel like
maybe you don't have someone to talk to
in your life but a therapist is such a
great resource for you and better help
is amazing it's so accessible because
it's done entirely online so if you've
been thinking of giving therapy a try
try with better help it's done entirely
online it's designed to be convenient
flexible and suitable to your schedule
just fill out a brief questionnaire to
get match with a licensed therapist and
switch therapist any time for no
additional charge so get a break from
your thoughts with better help better
help is just in my opinion so great
because gets rid of a lot of those like
awkward things that could be involved in
inperson therapy like if you don't Vibe
with your therapist it's like awkward to
change but with better help it's so easy
they'll help you switch totally normal
to not Vibe with like the first second
or even third person you're matched with
so visit betterhelp.com toast today to
get 10% off your first month that's
betterhelp
hp.com toast thank you Claudia you're
welcome our first story is a little
update on Joe and Sophie couple things
have come out one the name of their
second daughter has been revealed
through this process uh which I'm always
interested in celebrity baby names we
knew that their first daughter's name is
Willa and their second daughter is named
Del
we've just learned it's they're like I
think branding wise because Sophie's
like Queen of the North UK Queen like
they're so on brand and they jive well
together like Willa and deline like they
sound like you know mystical fairies in
a far off land like I actually think
those are both really excellent names
excellent names I love them both and I
love them together and they're very
unique but they're still names which I
think is so important in Celebrity
culture uniess is important but
sometimes we're just making up you need
to name your child a name it's only fair
to the child to give them a name that is
a name kids kids can be cruel yeah these
are beautiful names and um that was like
a you know a fun tinbit though I'm sure
I guess it came out from the documents
yeah which is like a terrible way for
everyone to find out especially since
they didn't want us to know so I do feel
bad like knowing I also don't think I
like fully put together that we didn't
know the name of their second child I
did just because I'm like hung up on kid
names days so hard so hard but this was
a a success and then also um reports are
coming out about what Joe heard Sophie
say on the ring camera or do I almost
chose that as a story on Thursday but
there it was like this big bombshell we
know what Joe saw on the ring and then
it was just like not giving it was not
it's what it just is that she was bad
mouthing him which is like half of an
answer but it shows that if it's true
that it's not like he saw her cheating
on him or doing something crazy she he
just allegedly heard her talking [__]
about him which is so [__] awkward it
is but like I'm sure Ben talked [__]
about me like I talked [__] about him
have he have you ever listened to this
podcast no that's true but like I'm sure
it was it was not good I'm sure it was
bad
and like gave him an indication of like
how she feel I'm sure it was bad you
know I have such mixed feelings on ring
cameras like I've seen so many so much
amazing footage of like you know people
getting proposed to it catching just
like life moments that are amazing it
being so helpful of course in a time of
need but then there's
like I saw you know someone in who lives
in Travis Kelsey's neighborhood got a
like a moment of tail or leaving
Travis's house and entering a car on the
curb heading to the game and it was just
like so intimate and like an invasion of
privacy cuz they like posted it
everywhere and I feel like it can it can
be a little bit invasive yeah when it's
not your property like when and it's not
your family you know how many times like
I've W walked to a party at someone's
house like knocked on the door and said
to Ben like H we better get out of here
in like 10 minutes like what if there
was a ring yeah yeah yeah well that I
don't live in the suburb so I'm not
accustomed to being like Ben let's shut
our mouths while we're walking up to the
house you have to I'm sure that you
would get accustomed to that and that's
fair game because like you're at the
person's house so like you have to pay
attention but it's like when a
neighbor catches someone doing something
and it's like that's not your business
it's really it's not your business but
also on the flip side like they could
catch something I I remember that doc
that documentary about that [__] who
killed his wife and two kids what was it
called like America sweethearts or
something yeah Chris something yes the
neighbor and the footage that they had
on their like home cameras was
instrumental in figuring out that it was
Chris yeah I think based on what like
what I see go around like the benefits
of of the rewards outweigh the risk yeah
especially in your own personal life you
know having cameras you capture things
that you need to capture but also like
the neighbor capturing you like I think
in general it would be helpful not
harmful right I mean how would you have
known you had a pum issue had it not
been for your Stellar home cameras is it
a posum I don't know I can't look at a
picture of it like oversized Rod I mean
even like mice like oversized rodents
like that is it's genuinely too much for
me there is a critter that's always at
the front of my house I don't know what
it is and it like triggers your alarms
yeah yeah yeah I don't know if it's a
posum I can't even Google pictures
because like no this animal is the
ugliest nastiest thing I've ever seen in
my life I thought it was an armadillo I
was going to say it was giving armadillo
it it's not of this world it's so
disgusting he doesn't around every night
but when he does it's it sends a shiver
down my spine armadillos are truly not
for this world okay let me describe what
and maybe someone could tell me I can't
even think about him I'm sorry
it he has like a cone shaped
face and then his body is like that of a
weener
dog oh like low and long in cylinder
cylindrical cylindrical and the
cylindrical goes all the way up to the
face where it turns into a cone and to
see a tail the tail I've not like gotten
up close in personal but I do think it's
like a rat tail hairless oh my God like
a hairless fleshy tail I'm actually
becoming like dizzy for real like I'm
I'm wooing imagine how I feel he walks
Among Us Jackie not me like ripping
Chloe Kardashian for like her fear of
whales but like her fear of whales but
this is different from being like you
know 20 ft away
a thousand miles away Cory gamble was
like calm down he's not coming in the
pool
like yeah calm down he's not coming in
your house but I know you're but he's
dangerously close to your home you have
just like sympathy pays for me 100%
that's so how did we get here how did we
get here ring camera ring camera how did
we get here how do we get out we need
like a little um button on our
soundboard where like we go on such a
crazy tangent and like while we're
talking about it one of us realizes How
Far We've steered from the conversation
we press the button I love that can we
actually do it we say that all the time
about stuff also like Hannah Montana
transitions like can we do stuff like
that why can't we do stuff like that why
not us we completely can I just believe
um I we have had this like the sound
system we use we've had for a couple of
years and we programmed like the CR
crunch on it so many years ago I have no
idea how to program sounds on it I'm
sure it's simple Google search if any
it's a simple search
if anybody knows how to upload
pre-recorded sounds to a roadter let me
know and I'll do it we could also do
those things in post but that's so not
us it doesn't hit the same yeah we need
to be able to dance to it how do we get
here how do we get out we used to give
him something to see oh baby look at us
now oh she's getting
groovy she's getting
groovy
she's swimming how do we get here how do
we get how do we get out we used to give
them something to see baby look at us
[Music]
now speaking of getting out are you
ready for our next
story get out leave right now speaking
of celebrities doing things car
Washington calls out Shaq for sliding
into her DMS so Andy Cohen had um car
Washington and Watch What Happens Live
and he asked who's the most famous
person to slide into your DMs wanting to
connect as a friend or otherwise and she
said Shaquille O'Neal no by the way a
ship she said he's a big Scandal fan
that's why because I do think Shaq is
married she was on the show to promote
her new Memoir thicker than water and
she shared that I would read her Memoir
yes she shared that Shaq likes to make
jokes referencing the plot of her show
Scandal which ran for Seven Seasons he's
always like quote I'll do anything for
command oh that's funny really funny
then she also shared that the most
famous person in her phone is Oprah and
the most recent celebrity to text her
was Jennifer Aniston but I feel like
Carrie Washington is like that famous
that you like duh does she hangs out
with Oprah and Jennifer andison yeah no
neither of those things are shocking to
me you know I don't watch Scandal but
they have like a huge fan base and I
sometimes end up on like Scandal talk
where they just like relive moments
between Tony Goldwin the president and
and Olivia Pope um but one of my
favorite like viral moments from the
Scandal fandom that I don't like I'm not
even a part of they did like an
Instagram live I think during Co just to
like give people something to do and
they were talking all about the show and
it was like so cute everyone was dying
for it and she goes Tony like what was
your favorite season or no she said it
exactly like this what's your favorite
season and he goes probably
fall and they're like dying of laughing
like can't stop and she's like no of
this show and they're like like it's
literally silent laughter for 30 seconds
it's honestly one of the funniest clips
on the internet that's good stuff yeah
it's good it's giving mug it's giving
mug people answering questions
improperly it's giving April 25th all
you need is a light jacket no that's
like one of my favorite comedic tropes
it's so innocent but it has to be
accidental of
course yeah what is your favorite
season probably fall honestly same
certainly fall chil SE
you have the anticipation of the
holidays but it's not over yet my
birthday Sweater Weather fall fashion
there's nothing better okay tell me if
this is like correct rankings of the
seasons because honestly I have to like
100% although I will say the last two
are interchangeable if you want
fall
spring summer
winter I think fall
spring I'm a winter girl winter I said
that I said the last two are
interchangeable yeah the first two are
certain I also think it depends on your
body type yeah
but like you know
100% like I'm not looking forward to
Summer no by the way it depends on where
you're at in your health Journey whether
summer will be third or fourth yeah and
whether honestly fall would be first or
second because if you're like you just
got snatched you can't wait for spring
to sprung no so I will say like third
and fourth are obviously interchangeable
but so our first and second yeah but
with each other not with the others but
that's also because third and fourth are
both the extremes and first and second
are both the pleasant oh yeah for sure
like the median Vibes median Vibes but
you're right I guess it can't be
Universal truths because we're all on
different Journeys and we all weigh
different amounts it's true yeah and we
all weigh different amounts throughout
the year cuz it's not even like it's not
just like me comparing myself to others
it's me comparing myself to myself and
like where I'm at and my life but let me
say this as like a former fat person and
like temporarily thin person emphasis on
the temporary um I still don't have warm
feelings towards Summer like I don't
like to sweat I don't like to Bear my
legs I don't like to shave my legs I
don't even really have like skinny legs
I have like jelly cellulite like I don't
know if maybe it's a weight thing maybe
it's like a confidence thing maybe but
you do like to
swim I love to swim but I find like
during the summer and I stand by this
summer like as an adult like you're
still working it's not all that fun I
find maybe I swim more in the winter
because I'm more conscious to like plan
trips yeah but I feel like maybe you
would feel differently if you had a
summer house if you had somewhere to be
but somewh in the city I should only be
so lucky somewhere in the city Dreadful
Dreadful so Dre but other people have
places to go and they look forward to
that but not us yeah like a goal of mine
like I don't really have like
aspirations when it comes to like being
a homeowner for my primary residence
like I don't I actually love renting
it's not like I think a lot of people's
goals is like to eventually own a home
one day I a goal of mine is to have a
second home but without having a first
yeah to have a vacation house yeah which
we've talked about endlessly but we just
can't ever make a decision like where
would it even be we can't even get that
far we can't even get that far but no
offense it's your fault because you
moved um no but we could do somewhere
equidistant where North Carolina no like
I'm I've never been more down for
anything in my life okay so location
settled okay you guys where do people
vacation in North Carolina that would be
good for us yeah like where we can get a
pool but there's also like a cute town a
cute town because we don't want to be
like in an actual like residential
neighborhood and where those people left
for the summer no where's like the
where's the mon talk of North Carolina
is it Myrtle Beach like that's South
Carolina no but like maybe there's a
lake I would do a lake town yeah yeah
but I need a pool
okay yeah let us know like what is
what's the Jersey Shore of North
Carolina but by the way because even if
it's like a lake town we could still go
there in the winter like yeah like
winter time snowy Lake Vibes Count Me In
winter spring summer or
fall and if you're like a leading real
estate agent in the region please we
just need someone to do the work for us
Opportunity Knocks we love working
Withers after every summer we're like
next summer we're doing something let's
do it
yeah maybe something mountainous Smoky
Mountains sure but also somewhere easily
accessible like with direct flights and
like no more than an hour from the
airport agreed
Tennessee I mean twist my arm Tennessee
it's not like a summer house kind of
state you know but why not it's
beautiful in the Summer according to
what I see when people travel there on
my
Instagram I I actually am really looking
forward to the comment section on our
YouTube so please drop a comment let us
know where should we get a second home
that we can both enjoy please let us
know where should we
summer are you ready for our next story
yeah you're like you will never be ready
for this story because you're never
going to care but I think there's people
out there Olivia ashre Who Care in sync
reunite with a pop Banger called better
place their first song together in over
20 years by the way I care you do like I
to an extent okay in sync is back
they've released a song called better
place the new song is off the soundtrack
for the upcoming movie trolls band
together which dropped on Friday after
the group began teasing it so it's like
not like in and gets back together
Justin Timberlake's big movie trolls I
guess they have a new movie coming out
about a band so Justin Timberlake's band
put out a song it makes a lot of sense
it no it makes a ton of sense and let's
we not forget the last song Justin
Timberlake did for the movie trolls I
got that sunshine in my pocket got that
good song in my feet got you walk
it it
drop like honestly this is something to
be excited about yeah if it's going to
be that quality of music right I didn't
realize Justin Timberlake is a star of
trolls which makes perfect
sense no but also Kelly's in it and the
song she released is so good it's broken
and it's
beautiful
oh no they kind of kill It soundtrack
wise in terms of of the trolls franchise
and I expect nothing less from insync
yeah I didn't listen to the song this
morning you know I was on my um Spotify
release radar and I scrolled right past
it but I'm glad that all of this hype
led to something real yeah people
thought it was going to be a tour and I
think they were like enormously let down
I feel like if the song does
well and Justin you know kind of falls
back into favor with the public cuz he's
a little out of favor a little oh right
a lot and not even just cuz I don't like
him but between Britney Britney and the
handholding Janet Jackson Janet Jackson
it hasn't been a good few years for
Justin Timberlake with all these
documentaries about the 90s somebody in
Hollywood decided like we're going to
release a bunch of documentaries that
all make Justin Timberlake look bad
about various topics like where Justin
isn't even the subject the Super Bowl
Janet Jackson one of course the Britney
one they just they did a bunch of
documentaries about a certain period of
time in Justin Timberlake it was a bad
few years for him
yeah so this yeah they couldn't they
couldn't like just launch a tour out of
nowhere like that's kind of Reckless
unclear if there is like a crazy demand
for it so I think this is them dipping
their toe in the idea of like
potentially working together in the
future I think they look at Backstreet
Boys and I don't think you know they
thought Back Street Boys would be
killing it in their reunion era for as
long as they are they had the Vegas
residency they have a tour that's like
really popular they really back stre
boys everybody put their egos aside and
they decided listen let's make a living
for our families and that's what they're
doing
yeah I don't think that Justin like
could do what the back Tre boys are
doing no because they really they did
all put their egos aside Humble Pie was
E Humble Pie like especially Nick Carter
like but what else do you have going on
honestly exactly they no they did the
work because they realized options were
limited yeah but so I think they'll
they'll take the
temperature
of this song Maybe another one maybe a
here what I what I hope to happen if
there is like an sync Renaissance like I
hope the energy we all collectively had
for Justin Timber Lake we have for JC
Shaz like I feel as though he was
grossly underrated in his prime I think
vocally you know
choreographically he's a star like he
really I I was surprised when like
Justin took off in the way I think it
really could have been JC and he's so
hot yeah but I think Justin was just
more of a political animal
100% And just one of my favorite things
like Facts of Life is that JC Shaz and
Eva Longoria dated and I think that it
was like the one true loves of both of
their lives even though I think they
went on like four dates yeah and she's
like really happily married I know to a
businessman Bo Mogul Edition right I
think he owns like
L'Oreal amongst other things yeah so
she's okay yeah and also um you know who
else kind of crushed it in the
businessman bow
field who Salma Hayek her husband is
like owner of lvmh which owner of the
world the world like that's as like
that's goals like that's a really a role
model we could and should all look up to
I completely agree no that actually like
when that is the most
businessman bow of them all there's no
bigger businessman on Earth yes it's
true Sal mahak and Eva Longoria are in
the businessman bow Hall of Fame Hall of
Fame so is Miranda Kerr
yeah you know let me start a list hold
on yes because this is important yeah
okay good and I'm going to look up like
I feel like I'm forgetting a couple
major players in the business but we're
going to figure it out and there's a lot
of people who are like businessmen
whatever but it's not the Hall of Fame
no no no I'm talking Hall of Fame Salma
hyek who was the second one you just
said oh evang goria Miranda Kerr yeah
okay wait there's literally a list South
China Morning Post six celebrities who
married billionaire businessmen oh well
they're divorced now but Jackson married
that prince who gave her $100 million to
have a baby oh that's nice but that
doesn't like resonate with me okay I
don't know who Jamie gerts is and is a
prince a
businessman no but it counts like yeah
Miranda KR is on this list wow I've
never heard of some of these celebrities
they're referring to which now would you
say Grimes is on this list no you
wouldn't say Elon is a businessman but
oh Hall of
Fame they're not married or even like
together they're
they just have children together while
being separated they just have children
together once a year okay here 17
celebrities who married into serious
money Salma Hayek is number one Miranda
Kerr is number two oh you know who but
they're not married yet Ashley Benson is
engaged to that oil
air which one party boy uh Brandon Davis
oh right but I don't think of him as
like the a businessman it's there's the
difference between like marrying someone
wealthy and like marrying a business man
no he's an heir same with a lot of
people on this list oh we could have but
they're divorced now kayy quogo was
married to Carl
cook but actually he's also an heir his
father invented into
it a lot of these people are a we can
make a list for heirs but that's a
different list no you're right all of
these people thus far are
airs h j the
Jackson oh my God I didn't know this El
mcfar you know her '90s Queen model yeah
was married to billionaire real estate
developer Jeffrey saer who everybody for
a point thought was Ben's Uncle even
though Ben does have an uncle named
Jeffree Sofer not the same one um who
owns like the fountain blue Hotel a huge
real estate mile but they are no longer
married they got divorced in 2017
Jeffree stoford came up on this show
recently why uh Ben always tells the
story of the time no he was in the news
for something oh yes he was rumored to
be dating Jazelle he was rumored to be
dating Jazelle
thank
you no there are a bunch of people on
this list who might have been eligible
but they're divorced so the list is
actually very small so far the list is
small but you know what all good lists
are succinct it's so true succinct it's
like there wasn't there wasn't a lot on
Google you know it's an accomplishment
to make it to this list it's not any old
schlub what story were we talking about
in
sync how did we get here
Timberlake JC Eva great great are you
ready for our next story is it our next
story that's brought to you by the game
time app Perhaps it is tury Lou you
shouldn't have to worry when you're
buying tickets to your next big event
game time is the fast and easy way to
buy tickets for all the sports music
comedy and Theater events near you with
killer last minute deals all in low
prices all in prices views from your
seat and their best guaranteed
guaranteed price game time takes the
guest work out of buying tickets I Love
Game Time For Us open for Eros tour the
Jets game this weekend I was stalking
game time game time's just a really good
app and they great Flash Deals and it's
just easy so you can see the view from
your seat before you buy which I love
they're all in prices show your total
amount up front so there's no you know
pulling one over on you where you go to
the end and it's like three times the
price no uh it's a you're getting a
great deal without hidden fees and you
can buy tickets in seconds with just two
Taps they have deals on tickets right up
to the start of the event or even an
hour after the event starts so it's the
really the place to find last minute
deals you're finding exclusive Flash
Deals and sponsored deals on tickets for
football basketball baseball concerts
comedy theater and more with Zone deals
you pick the section and Game Time picks
the seats for an average of 18% savings
and the game time guarantee means you'll
always get the best price and if you
find tickets in the same section and row
for Less game time will credit you not
100 but 110% of the difference so take
the guest work out of buying tickets
with Game Time download the game time
app create an account and use code toast
for $20 off your first purchase terms
apply again create an account with uh
and redeem code toast t o a s and you'll
get $20 off download game time today
last minute tickets lowest price guadan
today's episode is also brought to you
by liquid Ivy proper functional
hydration is essential and liquid IV is
the number one powdered hydration brand
in America their hydration multiplier is
the one product you're missing in your
daily routine this is your sign to just
stop stock up on liquid IV because when
you need it and you don't have it
there's nothing worse and there's so
many reasons you can need liquid IV like
if you're just looking to stay on top of
your hydration great you're hung over
liquid IV migraine liquid IV midday
crashed not feeling well don't know why
liquid IV with just one stick of liquid
IV you can hydrate real life two times
faster than water alone plus you're
getting essential vitamins and three
times the electrolytes as a leading
sports drink like if you're going to
have to drink water have it do the most
work for you you know just stick a pack
of liquid IV in there they come in 12
delicious refreshing flavors to keep
your hydration routine exciting one
stick into 16 ounces of water will
hydrate you two times faster and more
efficiently than water alone it contains
B3 B5 B6 B12 and vitamin C and three
times the electrolytes of a leading
sports drink it's non GMO it's free from
gluten dairy and soy and they believe
that Equitable access to clean and
abundant water is the foundation of a
healthier world so at liquid IV they
partner with leading organizations to
fund and Foster innovative solutions
that help communities protect their
water and their Futures to date liquid
IV has donated over 39 million servings
in over 50 countries around the world I
love the passion fruit flavor it's so
good always have it in your purse
especially when you're traveling so real
people real flavor real hydration grab
your liquid IV in bulk nationwide at
Costco or you can get 20% off when you
go to liquid i.com and use cod toast at
checkout that's 20% off anything when
you shop better hydration today using
promo code toast at liquid i.com today's
episode is also brought to you by papaya
so the perfect holiday gift for everyone
on your list it'll be the favorite thing
that they receive is the reusable paper
towels from papaya our newest and most
amazing toast
sponsor um so if you skip over this ad
you're a wench if you've always been a
disposable paper towel girly like I have
and you're just blowing through rolls of
paper towels it was not a good look for
me and it's not a good look for you so
papaya is mind-blowing each pack comes
with two of these reusable paper towel
sheets and one sheet is replacing 17
rolls of paper towels you can put them
anywhere love that and because the
founder of papaya is actually a huge
toaster she's giving fellow toasters 50%
off the entire site so go to papaya p a
p a y a re reusables re e u s a b l s .c
and use code toast for 50% off all right
what's our next story ja our next story
a bit of a throwback Gypsy Rose
Blanchard will be released from prison
early so just to jog your memory Gypsy
Rose Blanchard who was serving time in
prison for her role in the murder of her
mother has been granted Parole in the
schedule to be released in December said
uh Ozark's first on Thursday in by way
is it like a crazy take that Gypsy Rose
like shouldn't be prison no I don't I
don't think it's crazy take I think you
know oh some people feel she might have
been justified in what she did but like
murder's never the answer murder's
murder but like what her mother did was
like psychological terrorism right but
that also could be why she only got 10
years for murder and she's getting out
early and she's getting out early for uh
good behavior I'm assuming she will have
served 85% of her sentence for killing
her mother who um if you guys do not
remember Gypsy was the victim of munch
Housen by proxy syndrome which is a rare
form of abuse in which a guardian
exaggerates or induces illness in a
child for attention and sympathy gypsy's
mother convinced her friends family and
community that Gypsy was a terminally
ill teenager with the mind of a
seven-year-old who suffered from
muscular distrophy leukemia and other
ailments additionally Gypsy Rose alleged
her mother wouldn't allow her to speak
during doctor's visits and told her that
if she ever tried to escape police
wouldn't believe her so she didn't feel
like she could escape the abuse of her
mother so Gypsy and her boyfriend at the
time plotted to kill the mother which
they did and they
both you know were sh yeah I I'm not
shedding over tear any tears I don't
know like over de I'm not into big True
Crimes like I don't know what the what's
the take on Gypsy Rose like justice for
Gypsy like or put that [__] in jail
like I don't know but I feel like based
on what I know and I watched actually
the first few episodes of uh Joey King
and I can only see Joey King as Gypsy
Rose like when I saw a picture of Gypsy
Rose I'm like where's Joey King totally
you know what I think of when I think of
Gypsy Rose my whole perception of the
situation has been so warped by the show
the politician all I see is Zoe de yes
Zoe deuts whose character was definitely
inspired by Gypsy Rose yeah and it's
like well when I think about that
situation I don't remember if she kills
her mother and I'm just like well Zoe
Deutsch's character was kind of nuts so
that to me has like tainted the whole
Gypsy Rose situation that's literally
like my only perception it that's so
funny I forgot about the show the
politician that was such a good show for
like so many years I really enjoyed it
um but you know I could see Gypsy Rose
getting out and becoming like an
influencer people are it's so rare that
there's like a true crime Saga where
people it like captures a nation and the
the person is still alive and is coming
out of jail I feel like we become
obsessed with like certain people and
they're Runing in jail or they ended up
dead this is like real life it kind of
reminds me of Jordan
Turpin oh right who is I follow her on
Tik Tok she like dances and stuff and
people love her like she's kind of an
influencer you know what in the
politician Zoe deutch's character
becomes an influencer oh my God
Elizabeth Smart is an influencer yeah
but they commit murder anad Deli no but
they their characters in
Nationwide in crimes that captured a
nation yeah but I feel like no they're
not all the same Elizabeth Smart is not
anad Deli no but I feel like with
Elizabeth smart and Jordan turp and it's
like so many people want to support them
I feel like with Anna delie I don't even
know does she have an
Instagram I think so I feel like she
wouldn't even have a lot of followers I
feel like it's the media who's like
props her up and makes her like this
darling they're like anad Del's mus
haves for house arrest it's like nobody
[__] asked and if they cared like we
could follow her on Instagram and she
could put link her Amazon storefront and
you know what people people will buy if
they want to buy and support her but I
feel like nobody actually like is into
anadelia except for like the media
making her something sounds like you're
suggesting that anad Deli is an industry
plant Claudia that's exactly what I'm
saying I I love that take I I'm obsessed
with that take and here's the thing when
the initial story about like the the
grifter came out I was so fascinated
like I read the story oh my God we did a
whole episode on the toast about it you
guys have to read this story and then I
moved on with my life because like it's
not the ROM any normal person should
she's not the Roman Empire there's not
that much there there but they don't
stop with her and I'm like documentaries
TV shows events events like everything
interviews articles podcast her show
they're giving her a show about like
having dinner guests and house arrest
like I don't give a [__] about this girl
sound off for the comments do you give a
[__] about anad delvia or is she an
industry plant it's giving industry
plant I'm telling you no I love that
you're so right way to think critically
Jax that's my specialty you also put
your iPad down and if if I'm not
mistaken that was only the fourth story
yeah I don't know I need to like rewatch
all the times I put my iPad down like
there's something about what I've just
said where that makes me feel like I'm
done here yeah but you're not am I
correct no you're 100% right I'm like go
she's getting comfortable but I think
the reason why I thought it was over is
because this story is giving very fifth
Story energy it is wait what was the
story again so you know what I look
forward to seeing what sort of
opportunities wait for Gypsy upon her
release from
yeah me too and our fifth and final
story is actually not fifth Story energy
but it's kind of like how I want to lead
into the weekend but wait also it must
be really crazy for Gypsy Rose because
not only has she been in prison for 10
years so she like doesn't know what life
on the outside is like she was really
under like permanent house arrest before
that like she never had a phone or a
computer like she probably has no idea
what it's like to be like a normal
however old she is like 25-year-old yeah
she probably had more exposure to
culture in prison yeah honestly it
probably was like a slow way to learn
about you know TV shows I'm sure she
watched TV in prison a bunch of other
stuff maybe played some games like met
people like she didn't talk to anyone
yeah it's crazy she honed her social
skills yeah she's ready she's she ready
she ready our fifth and final story as I
said not fifth Story material just how I
want to go into the weekend okay Taylor
Swift is set to be at the Jets game on
Saturday to watch Travis or Sunday to
watch Travis Kel and the Chiefs take on
the Jets so we need to wrap up the
weekend talking about what we've what
we've experienced this week what's gone
on in this country now totally
separately I was thinking this morning
like I just don't know when I got to a
place in my life where I was talking
about so many people named Travis Travis
Barker Travis Kelsey Travis Scott like I
just feel like it all happened at once I
I never like you know spoke about Travis
and now here I am talking endlessly
about Nam every time I say Travis in
regards to Travis Kelce I'm like is that
his name I don't know why it doesn't
suit him you know what I agree
especially when we're say like Taylor
and
Travis it's I'm like I don't think
Kelsey yeah no I feel
that no and when you're life is your
sport and you like run around with your
last name on your back like his name is
Kelsey his name is Kelsey 87 right right
first name Kelsey middle name 80 last
name seven yeah well sources are saying
she's going to be at the big game this
weekend which is you know among the
reasons why tury will be in attendance
and letting us know what's going down
but I am just so shook not over the fact
that they're dating which is the
craziest thing but like the way that
this country has gone wild for it and
I've really been thinking about like how
why how did we get here how do we get
out and I feel like the swifties and
football fans are two of like the
biggest communities in our country yep
Millions yep and they've come together I
also think that a lot of football fans
not to be gendered but I'm going to be
are married to swifties and this was so
exciting for so many people because you
know wives are used to their husbands
leaving them all day Sunday and husbands
are used to their wives talking
endlessly about Taylor Swift and having
knowing no idea what's going on so like
husbands wives boyfriends girlfriends
cousins like people just all around are
finding common ground on with two very
different communities the swifties and
football fans
so I think everyone's leaning in even
more because it's really bringing them
together yeah it's a beautiful thing I
think we're we're a country desperate
for unification for real we're desperate
for Unity and this is a prime example of
that yeah it's it's kind of a beautiful
thing now of course it makes you
worry what happens when you know
potentially it doesn't end well but I
think it will never get that serious
that feelings will be hurt on either
side and I think hopefully they can be
friends cuz I'm like I just know they're
not lasting like that I know for sure I
don't know many things have you seen um
his ex-girl friend who was the winner of
catching Kelsey I saw today on Twitter
she did like Entertainment Tonight like
it went to her home she's really
annoying me yeah so the there's all
these articles Travis's ex like calls
Taylor 5 Travis's ex like says that he's
like a cheater whatever and it's not
Travis's X it's the girl who won
catching Kelsey and I'm pretty sure such
an important distinction important
distinction and I remember I was a fan
of the show I watched it I'm pretty sure
live on E so when she won I was like
following their relationship and there
was nothing to follow they like were
never together I think they like hung
out the night that she won and then
moved on so I grain of salt grain of
salt
also to come out and say I'm a girls
girl like I think Taylor should know
that he cheated on me to say that to the
Daily Mail is not you being a girls girl
it's you being a thirst monster which I
respect for sure right but I just be
honest I I just don't think there was
ever a relationship to cheat on like I I
doubt they ever reached a period of
exclusivity but that's just what I think
but I feel really strongly about it yeah
no they say they dated for four months
which is by the way in and of itself
like a fake relationship four months and
especially when it's TV and you were
probably required to do like a bunch of
press afterwards like so perhaps you
work together for four months solely
because of circumstance and maybe he
didn't take it so seriously because it
was a fake dating show like let's be
real right and also like maybe they went
on a few dates over the course of 4
months but they were like boyfriend and
girlfriend for four months I feel
strongly about that I agree and it's
important to make those distinctions
yeah so I don't think Taylor's losing
sleep no me neither but the girl's
really annoying me yeah but wouldn't you
do the same thing oh my God I would be
worse right no I said I understand but
she's not owning her thirsty Hood she's
pretending to be like a girls girl I
feel like could no and like Pig jorbo
said on the toast yesterday any girl
who's has to say she's a girls girl is
just not because if you were we would
know it and you wouldn't have to say it
that's so true I've never said it about
myself that's what you said people who
like call themselves down to earth like
you're the worst person I've ever met
people who actually are down toe don't
need to say it and it doesn't need to be
said about them it just is a fact so
true yeah she's like the guys who I know
who call themselves Down to Earth are
literally diabolical demons like yeah
you don't say it you just are I feel
like she should have played this like
you know Travis and I had a great time I
love Taylor I feel like they'll be such
a great couple then it would be like
Travis's ex supports you know and it
would be positive reinforcement anything
she said would have gotten picked up so
the fact that she had to be negative and
like jealous it's giving bitter wench
and like calling Taylor a five oh please
what's that about no what's that about
let's not lie like you know nothing in
in life is you know Universal but like
Taylor Swift is a beautiful woman like
let's not lie and if Taylor Swift is a
five good luck to the rest of us okay
six feet tall blonde perfect body
gorgeous face Perfect Teeth big lips
like that's a five oh God what does that
make me she's a beautiful woman and she
should be wearing those shoes yeah
because she was qualified to own them
and that's that on that so that's our
final episode of the week hope everybody
enjoyed a fabulous week if I do say so
myself we have another fabulous week
here let me give it a little little
sneak peek to what's going on yeah and
let me know my days please yeah yeah we
have to we have to figure out next week
but I have on so you're on Mon oh no
that's last week you're on Monday right
oh October 3rd is really good on October
3rd he asked me day it was on October
3rd we have should I say yeah Jake Shane
the octopus lover of Tik Tok who is the
biggest toaster who is so funny like has
the best personality and is also just
like obsessed with pop culture and I
just I have so many questions for him
Wednesday I believe Jax is back yes
Thursday Hannah burner amazing Friday
ending the week with ja Perfection what
more could you want literally nothing so
thank you guys so much for listening to
the toast Millay Morning Show we deliver
the fast stories every Monday Friday
YouTu watching on YouTube please to
subscribe video thumbs
up and wickedly talented we are hope you
guys have an amazing weekend happy Su
coot to everyone celebrating and we'll
see you back on Monday by love you
bye